okay Thank You Tomas bird for the
introduction and thank you all for
abandoning the beautiful Berkeley
weather to come and sit in a dark room
and and watch a talk this talk is going
to be a little more oh reflective and
philosophical and a little less
technical than some that have gone by
but if you'll bear with me at the end of
it there are a couple there are a few
interesting research problems that I'll
get to eventually both in the area of
algorithms and in the area of software
systems so I hope that will make things
worthwhile my my thesis in this talk is
that for the last 50 years or so graph
algorithms and computing on large graphs
have served scientific computation have
served in particular sparse matrix
computation and and in some ways some of
the largest computations that were done
on graphs before about ten years ago
were in fact for the purpose of doing
sparse matrix computation now the
pendulum has swung back and now I think
sparse matrix matrix computation in
general is if you will returning the
favour'
to graph algorithms after after all
these years so that's that's quite a
saga if you don't like listening to the
talk the movie will be out in December I
think so so you can wait for that but
let's start with well let's start with
Markowitz so so Harry Markowitz is an
economist
still living was was an economist
working at RAND Corporation in the 1950s
doing linear programming using the
simplex method to essentially invent
portfolio theory and then efficient
front efficient frontiers of risk versus
reward and that
and and that sort of thing and in the
process he did matrix computation and
it's probably true that he made up the
term sparse matrix ah this is this quote
is actually from the 1990s rather than
the 1950s but he's describing that work
he says I observed that in most of the
that most of the coefficients in our
matrices were zero ie the non zeros were
sparse in the matrix and typically the
triangular matrices associated with
forward and back solution provided by
Gaussian elimination would remain sparse
if pivot elements were chosen with care
okay he was doing a numerical
computation but he's describing a
combinatorial problem in that quote um
he won the Nobel Prize for economics in
1990 not first barse matrix computation
but for portfolio theory but still it's
kind of nice that combinatorial
scientific computing has at least one
Nobel Prize to its name so this is the
combinatorial problem that that
Markowitz was talking about we have we
have here a matrix I'm going to stick
for the time being two symmetric
positive definite matrices because that
will let me not have to talk about
numbers and partial pivoting and
stability and so forth at all so my
matrices are just are just squares with
black dots in them so since it's a
symmetric matrix it's it's graph is an
undirected graph right 10 by 10 matrix
ten vertex graph and what Gaussian
elimination means for a symmetric
positive-definite matrix is is chill s
key factorization symmetric Gaussian
elimination and it produces a triangular
factor equals ll transpose and as
Markowitz said the triangular factor may
remain sparse if pivot elements are
chosen with care so and so in this case
there are five or six or so non zeros in
the triangular factor that we're not
nonzero in their original matrix and so
we could draw this graph here to
represent the nonzero structure of the
cholesky factor so the new the non-zeros
and the factor are called fill or fill
in usually and just by looking at the
graph there's a there's a very simple
recipe for creating this graph from this
graph which is we go through the
vertices in order that is we go through
the pivots in the matrix and as we touch
each vertex as we mark each vertex if
you will we add edges between its
between its higher numbered neighbors
and if you think about it for a second
that's just describing the rank one
update that happens at one step of
Gaussian elimination a fact that's true
Markowitz
I don't think knew it but but Don Rose
did not not too many decades later is
that is that if you start with a
symmetric matrix and do symmetric
factorization the factor that you the
factor that you get is actually a
chordal graph that is it's it's a graph
in which every cycle of more than three
vertices has a cord shortcutting it so
that four cycle there eight nine four
ten is shortcut by the edge nine ten for
example okay if the pivot a if the pivot
elements are chosen with care what does
that mean well you have a choice of how
to how to choose pivot elements here's a
here's a little graph or if you will a
little matrix you know think of that as
a matrix it's it's the same it's the
same object just a different picture of
it and here here here's the first vertex
when we when we eliminate it we add an
edge between its higher numbered
neighbors two and five then we eliminate
two at that point at the point it's
eliminated twos higher numbered
neighbors are five three and four so the
graph fills in completely and and and we
get this graph which is a which is K 5
which is chordal sure enough however
we're we're free to number the vertices
of the graph differently if we want to
so so if we perform a symmetric
permutation of the matrix so so P is a
permutation matrix here we're solving
you know solving
x equals B this is this is solving the
same linear system just with a different
numbering of variables and and now we
see we eliminate this vertex it has only
one neighbor so so we got no fill we
eliminate this one it has only one
higher numbered neighbor and so forth
nothing fills in and in fact sure enough
our original graph was was chordal so so
that's the so that's uh that's that's uh
that's Markowitz is problem
combinatorially I believe that the first
paper on this was by Seymour parter and
in in 1960 whoo-hooo proved a theorem
that in this terminology would be stated
as trees are chordal also also true
trees have no cordless cycles partners
partners paper showed that if you have a
matrix whose nonzero structure is a tree
you can eliminate eliminate it without
fill um so here's so here's the here's
the here's the thing here's here's
here's what we're doing if we can think
it we can think of this as a as a sort
of one-person game on a graph we
repeatedly choose a vertex of the graph
and mark it and we add edges between its
unmarked neighbors the goal of the game
is to end up with as with as few edges
as possible or equivalently the goal is
is minimum chordal completion is to add
as few edges as possible to the graph to
make it chordal and we can we can look
at the chordal graph and read off the
read off parameters that tell us the
complexity of actually performing the
elimination on it the amount of space
that we need is of course the the number
of the number of non-zeros in the matrix
or the number of edges and vertices in
the graph I can write that as the sum
over the vertices of for each vertex the
number of higher numbered neighbors plus
one that's a peculiar way to write down
the number of edges and vertices in an
undirected graph but then it turns out
that the amount of work the number of
earth matech operations to do the
factorization is sort of a second moment
of this sequence it's the sum of the
squares
one plus the one plus the number of
higher numbered neighbors
okay and this goes on and on and on and
this isn't really I don't want this I
love talking about this stuff that I'm
not intending to spend a whole a whole
half-hour talking about talking about
chordal completion but where it where
where it goes where it ends up going is
into an algorithm that's called nested
dissection which is originally due to
Alan George in the in the early 1970s in
his in his Stanford PhD thesis and has
gone there are there are many many many
papers on nested dissection up through
up through last last year if you look at
literature but what it is is a
divide-and-conquer algorithm for finding
a chordal completion for finding and
finding an elimination ordering as you
would expect finding the best quartile
completion is and be hard so you do
heuristics and approximations and this
is this is the approximation that turns
out to be the most successful in
practice on very large problems which is
a fairly simple divide and conquer
algorithm we take our graph and we find
a set of vertices who which is a
separator which which cuts it
approximately in half and then we do an
ordering in which we take those
separator vertices and order them last
and proceed recursively on the two
halves of the graph so we get this this
elimination tree if you well this tree
decomposition of the graph which is
actually reflected in the reflected in
the matrix two you get these sort of
nested sub matrices if you if you if you
look at the non zero structure of the
matrix this turns out to be as I said
generally speaking the most successful
approach in practice for very large
matrices although it's not the one that
Markowitz used and it also turns out to
be the right thing to do in theory it
turns out that if you can approximate
optimal separators in a graph you can
approximate optimal chordal completion
guy BLET talked about separators a
little bit this morning many of the
graphs that come up in scientific
computing have natural embeddings in two
dimensions or three dimensions because
they're representing two or three
dimensional physical problems of some
sort and the graphs that discretize
those those those problems tend to have
separators planar graphs have square
root of n separators of course looked at
ant Arjun and well-shaped finite element
mesh is in three dimensions have
separators of size and the 2/3 vertices
which is what you get by cutting a cube
in half that's a theorem that took many
years to prove not because it was such a
hard theorem but because you needed the
right definition of what exactly it
meant to have a graph that was embedded
in three dimensions because any graph
can be to invented in three dimensions
right there are separator theorems for
some other classes of graphs
most of them come with efficient
algorithms but nobody uses them because
in fact in practice heuristics do all
right and and here maybe you could just
finish off talking about separators I'll
just say that that graph separator
heuristics graph partitioning heuristics
have been an active area of research for
many many years
with lots of different applications but
for a long time for with the application
of sparse direct methods here and so
here are some heuristics that have been
used the sparse direct methods community
was doing spectral partitioning fairly
early and there are there are lots of
other things guy this morning mentioned
the meatus code which is one of the what
you would consider a modern graph
partitioning heuristic most of the
modern codes use a sort of multi-level
iterative swapping well I'll just say
multi-level iterative swapping approach
so okay so that was that was a lot about
one particular place that graph
algorithms show up in sparse matrix
computation but in fact in fact they're
ubiquitous there were
there are many many graph algorithms
that have been either used or invented
for the purpose or at any case
implemented at fairly large scale
large-scale for the time at least for
for the purpose of doing sparse matrix
computation so in the symmetric
factorization problems that we've been
talking about their algorithms on trees
algorithms to predict the non zero
structure of the output of a matrix
computation without actually performing
the computation as far as triangular
solve sparse sparse this farce that
given an elimination order you can you
can reorder the elimination tree
efficiently actually to have minimum
minimum minimum span minimum parallel
height and so forth for non symmetric
direct methods you get again algorithms
for sparse triangular solves bipartite
matching comes in crucially and non
symmetric problems strongly connected
components or it's generalization
dolmage Mendelson decomposition and so
forth and then of course iterative
methods for solving systems of linear
equations also are full of our full of
graph algorithms graph partitioning
shows up again this time for the purpose
of partitioning a problem for parallel
computation independent sets and
coloring come in four for
preconditioning of various kinds low
stretch spanning trees show up for pre
conditionings of various kinds Yvonne
Toledo tomorrow will give a talk that
has low stretch spanning trees in it and
and and so forth and so on
let me not let me not as I say let me
not go on and on about graph algorithms
I could I could mention one one last one
which is which is this I said sparse
triangular solve because this actually
looks a little bit like this actually
looks a little bit like like some big
graph probing problems so what we're
given is is a big dag a big directed
acyclic graph and a very a very sparse
right hand side vector and we want to
compute the answer to the linear system
which is itself expected to be sparse
so what that means is is search in the
graph to find out where the non-zeros
are going to be and then proceed in
topological order to actually compute
compute the values and that that gets
used in in lots of these codes okay so
so sparse cholesky factorization
pre-ordering all of this stuff is done
in in approximately in in nearly linear
time in the size of the data than the
numerical factorization goes blindingly
fast because it can use a static data
structure and because it can use Blas
three to reduce memory traffic blas
three what's that okay so this goes back
to the graph theory again Corella graphs
have a nice natural representation a
chordal graph is a tree of overlapping
clicks a clique is a dense clique is a
complete sub graph a complete sub graph
is a dense matrix and dense matrix
operation operations do n cubed work on
N squared data and therefore use memory
efficiently and so because of this fact
that a chordal graph can be represented
as cliques most of the actual arithmetic
and Gaussian elimination can be done in
in dense matrix computation this is just
a picture of that oh this is an aside I
want you to remember this until the very
end of the talk although you don't have
to remember the details of it if you're
in a non-symmetric world so so now you
want an A equals Lu factorization and
you need to do partial pivoting you need
to do numerical pivoting for stability
all you can one one thing that you can
do is reorder columns for for all these
combinatorial things and then it turns
out that column permutations of this
matrix look like symmetric permutations
of the symmetric positive-definite
matrix a transpose a and so you would
sort of like to carry over all this
technology and the point that I want you
to remember till the end is that over
the years the the sparse matrix folks
have figured out how to do all these
combinatorial things
on the graph of a transpose a without
actually forming it based on based on
our data structure for a it's mostly not
that hard but it's a bunch of special
cases okay so in summary linear algebra
occupies a sort of magical position as
the middleware of scientific computing
if you will by middleware I mean that
traditional scientific computing is
usually trying to model the physical
world the mathematics is usually
differential equations of some sort real
numbers continuous problems infinite
field you know things that are not
really too good a match to to the add
subtract multiply divide things that the
computers do so linear algebra sort of
sits in the middle translating
discretizing
approximating linearizing these
continuous problems into add subtract
multiply divide problems things that
things that computers can do okay and
the pendulum swings back so now here we
are at a conference where we're not
talking about well some of us are
talking about physical modeling but but
mostly we're talking about big data
analysis problems analyzing discrete
structures where the problem starts out
as a discrete problem it doesn't start
out as a differential equation or or a
figure in three space we have the same
computers add subtract multiply divide
at the bottom and so presumably the
mathematical middleware that goes here
is graph theory so 50 years of
computational linear algebra have gotten
us really really good at executing this
this schema for for physical modeling
presumably we just plug in graph theory
instead of linear algebra and and and
this works too so how's that going
well linear algebra and graph theory
both have standard benchmarks that
you've heard about here for for linear
algebra for floating-point computation
the benchmark is something called the
top 500 bench
mark or the Linpack benchmark it's
essentially a floating-point computation
benchmark the benchmark is to solve a
large system of linear equations by
Gaussian elimination with partial
pivoting and every six months since the
early 1970s sometime the the top500
organization has has created a list of
the fastest machines in the world by
this definition and so the last list was
at the June European supercomputing
conference the next one will come out
next month at the supercomputing
conference here here in Denver and the
top of the list at the moment which you
can't read here is the the rate you
measure is terras flops floating-point
operations per second and the top the
top the the winner is is 33 points
something petaflop s-- so there's also a
graph 500 benchmark which you've heard
mentioned a couple of times here this is
much newer it's only been around for
about three years but the goals of the
list are quite similar every six months
to two to run the benchmark on as many
machines as possible there aren't 500 of
them yet on the list so you can get your
iPhone on the on the graph 500 list if
you want to but the but the benchmark
here is again a computational kernel in
this case breadth-first search in a
large power law graph a randomly
generated approximately power log graph
in our mat graph and the right now is
measured in terms of fundamental
operations which are called taps edges
traversed edges per second since there's
no floating point in this computation
and here are the winners and the winner
at the moment is is this Blue Gene
machine at Livermore and here's the rate
15 point 3 Giga taps
billions and billions of edges per
second so so how does that compare as of
as of last summer we could do
floating-point at 33 Peto flops and
and graphs at fifteen Tara taps and the
ratio is about two thousand or so so so
what does that mean does that mean that
we're two thousand times worse at doing
graph computation than the matrix
computation probably not not not really
I think it means two things one is one
is that this is a harder computation
than this when this benchmark was
defined the hard thing was to do a
floating-point arithmetic computation
but nowadays arithmetic is practically
free and communication is what costs
money moving data is what costs energy
and time and a random graph traversing a
random graph moves a lot of moves a lot
of data around so maybe maybe two orders
of make three orders of magnitude isn't
surprising but the number that I think
is more interesting is to look
historically you can't go very far back
the graph 500 benchmark is three years
old now but three years ago the ratio
was 400,000 so this ratio has gone down
by a factor of almost 200 in two and a
half years and so what does this say in
in in three years two and a half
petaflop 233 petaflop s-- we haven't
really learned anything new about how
you do dense Gaussian elimination
we've just belt machines with more cores
and more memory and maybe faster quacks
since since since 2010 and that's this
gain but nobody's built machines in the
last two and a half years that are two
hundred times as good at doing graph
computations as they were three years
ago most of this game is computer
science most of this gain is is is
algorithms and software and just
figuring figuring out how to do this
problem right and and this is this is in
some way sort of maybe the most
important part of the talk but let me
let me go on okay so a lot of a lot of
the gain a lot of what was learned in
doing the top500 benchmark and and all
the other numerical computations of the
last 50 years
is that primitives matter so this is uh
this is a chart that I probably stole
from either Cathy Alec or Larry Carter
I'm not sure who it's a it's a it's a
it's a very old chart that shows as a
proportion of the peak floating-point
rate of a machine how fast as a function
of the size of a vector or matrix does a
primitive basic primitive go and the
basic primitives here are blahs one
vector vector operations matrix vector
operations and matrix matrix operations
of course the big gain at the Blas 3
level is that you get the N n cubed work
for n squared N squared data movement so
so what we're learning now is how to do
common is is what the right primitives
for combinatorial computation could be
so what should the combinatorial blahs
look like this is an old slide I showed
this slide I showed this slide several
years ago when when I de mulege was a
graduate student and and as graduate
students tend to be a little confused he
somehow thought it was a thesis topic
rather than a talk and so and so I
didn't I didn't yesterday gave a talk
about about using using sparse arrays
and sparse matrices over semi rings as
computational primitives for graph
computation i won't i won't i won't
repeat all of that the canonical example
is is breadth-first search this is a
multi source breadth-first search here
written as a matrix problem here written
as a graph problem again they're the
same picture they're there even the same
data structures and the same work
they're just they're just slightly
different drawings of it
one thing about writing it this way
though is that you automatically get a
lot of different ways to get parallelism
right columns of X are parallelism over
different searches columns of a is
parallelism over vertices in a frontier
rows of a is parallelism over the edges
out of a single high degree vertex and
so you can do other things you can do
graph contraction and sub graph
extraction you can do between the
centrality if you want thanks to thanks
to Eric Robinson
you can actually do all sorts of things
Jeremy Kepner a few years ago did a did
a study about about trying to do
fundamental graph algorithms in the
language of linear algebra and and he
and I a couple of years ago even even
wrote a book about it one of the points
as iDEN mentioned is that these are
matrices over arbitrary semi rings the
point is that the computations have the
same data reference pattern and control
flow no matter what the no matter what
the semi ring is so so the semi ring you
know might be the real field it might be
boolean zit might be the tropical this
is the shortest path semi ring really
the way to think of a semi ring and this
sort of thing is that the objects are
attributes on the edges of vertices and
there's an aggregation operation that
happens at vertices and there's some
kind of intervertebral so so let me so
let me let me see I promise to ask some
questions so let me ask some questions
real quick John Barry at Sandia is the
architect of the multi threat Sandia
multi-threaded graph library one of the
most successful large-scale graph
libraries and and is the loyal
opposition for for us on this project
and so and so he oh you're so ago gave
us a set of gave us expounded a set of
challenge problems for the linear
algebra approach and so and so I give
them to you we know how to do many of
them efficiently you can do anything in
anything of course but we know how to do
most but not all of those efficiently in
linear algebra another question this is
probably a good place to end but I told
you to keep this question and mine till
the end so I guess I owe you an
explanation of why remember that that
the sparse matrix people knew how to do
all these all these algorithms
on a transpose a without forming a
transpose a when you write down a graph
algorithm as well and as linear algebra
often what happens is that you're sort
of artificially inserting bsp steps or
barriers in between pieces of the
computation and you often would like to
do that without storing all those
intermediate results so so joy gonzales
yesterday talked about graphlab about
about his graph parallelism and one of
them you know it's it's the same idea of
aggregating things across edges at
vertices but one of the important parts
of that is is is scheduling is sort of
not dividing it into into into into
these into these into these sort of
artificial giant steps boil the ocean I
don't have time to talk about boiling
the ocean well boy boil the ocean some
other time let me finish by going back
to the blahs the numerical gloss it's
hard to overstate the impact that the
development the definition of the blahs
have had on numerical scientific
computation over the last forty years
they really have made it possible to
separate concerns between experts in
mapping algorithms onto Hardware who can
make the blahs run fast and experts in
linear algebra who can build software on
top of the Blas that will run fast for
free more or less so what about graphs
could be define the graph pause well my
answer to that question is no and yes
no I don't think we're anywhere near
ready to standardized tools for graph
algorithms there's you know huge
diversity and what kinds of algorithms
how people match algorithms to hardware
there are many different data structures
many different linguistic primitives
lots of algorithms work still to be done
before we even know what we want to do
no but I think that by now there are
enough people who are doing graph
who are using this sort of sparse array
linear algebraic approach to doing graph
algorithms that the time may be here for
standardizing a set of interfaces and
API for doing graphs in linear algebra
and so and so this is this is where I'm
going to end there is in fact now a
graph Blas forum chaired by Tim Matson
of Intel and a steering committee of a
few people and a group of dozens of
people who wrote a position paper
including including our loyal opposition
John Barry is there somewhere intending
intending to intending to define a
standard so so I'll leave you with that
but I'll invite you to sign up and
there's my conclusion so so matrix
computation is beginning to repay this
50-year old debt and sometimes things
are clearer if you look at them from two
directions so thank you very much